هذه هي السيارة التي قادها براد بيت وفي
يوم من الأيام في هوليوود
[موسيقى] ،
نحن أكبر مزود للسيارات السينمائية في
هوليوود ، لذلك هناك فرصة جيدة
إذا شاهدت فيلمًا بسيارة وفريق
من قانوننا ، اسمي شون  Grogan أنا
أحد مديري التصنيع في سيارات السومو ،
لدينا حوالي 1100 سيارة في
أي مكان من سيارات الشرطة ، والإسعاف ،
والحافلات المدرسية ، سيارات الخمسينيات ، سيارات الأربعينيات ، سيارات الثلاثينيات ،
المركبات العسكرية ، المقطورات ، سيارات الأجرة ،
حافلات السجن ،
بعض سياراتنا في حالة جيدة
تعطل بسبب الحروق ، أعني سمها ما شئت ،
لقد حصلنا على الكثير ، لقد عملنا في هذا
المجال لأكثر من 40 عامًا ، لقد
قدموا الكثير من الأفلام ، لكن بعض الأفلام التي
قد تتعرف عليها ستختفي في 60
ثانية
والرجل العنكبوت المفقود المنتقمون 2 The Hangover السيد.
والسيدة.  ساعة الذروة في سميث والقائمة
تطول وتطول
[الموسيقى]
في متجرنا ، لدينا قسم تنجيد
لدينا قسم تصنيع
لدينا قسم ميكانيكي
للطلاء والجسم
وقسم رسومات
بالطريقة التي تعمل بها شركة إنتاج
سيتصلون بنا ويقولون إنهم
يصورون فيلمًا جديدًا ويحتاجون إلى XY &
Z وسيقومون بإرسال هذا
الرسم بشكل أساسي لما يريدونه ومن ثم فإن
مهمتنا هي تحويل هذا الرسم إلى
واقع من التحديات التي
نواجهها  في العثور على مضاعفات
نفس السيارة ، لذا قمنا في وقت ما
بتحويل بيك آب شيفروليه سيلفرادو إلى
رولز رويس لفيلم الساحر
المبتدئ ، نذهب إلى أي موقع من بين ملايين
المواقع حيث يمكنك العثور على سيارات مستعملة
ليست لديهم  لتكون في
حالة تشغيل طالما أنها تبدو جيدة
ويمكننا جعلها تعمل مرة أخرى ، فهذا هو
الجزء الأكثر أهمية بمجرد وصول هذه
السيارة إلى المتجر ، حيث سيطلب من فريق التصميم لدينا
إجراء بعض التصاميم والرسومات
وتحديد الأشياء من هناك.
ستغير الحافظة المقاعد ، ربما
سيكون لدينا أغطية مقاعد ، ربما تكون أغطية المقاعد ،
بمجرد أن يعمل متجر التنجيد
على جزء منها ، يقوم
فريق التصنيع ببناء
أجزاء مخصصة عند اكتمال السيارة ، وسوف
ينتقل إلى متجر Paint & Body Shop الخاص بنا ومن
هناك سوف يقومون بجميع أعمال الهيكل
اللازمة لجعل السيارة تبدو كما لو كانت
بدائية ، وبعد ذلك سيتم إدخالها
وسيقومون بطلائها ثم يقوم الميكانيكيون
بفحص سوائل فحص مجموعة نقل الحركة
والتأكد من عدم وجود تسريبات.
اختبار قيادة تأكد من أن
الفرامل جيدة ولكن تأكد من أنه عندما تكون
هذه السيارة في وضع التشغيل لا تتعطل ،
فإن الخطوة الأخيرة هي أن يقوم فريق الرسومات
بطباعة تلك الشعارات ثم
تثبيت الرسومات
ومن هناك سوف يشعر فريق الإنتاج
بالراحة  السيارات فوق ثم لا نراهم
مرة أخرى حتى ينتهي تصوير الفيلم
[موسيقى]
نحن هنا في المبنى C حيث نحتفظ
بالكثير من سياراتنا التي تحتاج إلى البقاء في
الداخل ولدينا سيارة بونتياك فايربيرد الجميلة هذه
بأبواب انتحارية من  الاتصالات
القديمة  تجاري في كنتاكي فرايد تشيكن
أعتقد أنه يبدو جيدًا جدًا ، أحد الأشياء
المفضلة لدي هو من فيلم The Hangover
لكنهم كانوا يدفعون في Brown مقابل
فيلم آخر شاهدته من قبل ،
وكلاء الدرع هذه الكورفيت الحمراء هي Lola نحن
فخورون بالعمل  التي نقوم بها هنا في
السيارات السينمائية ، لن
تعمل هوليوود بالطريقة التي تعمل بها بدوننا
عندما نرى سياراتنا على الشاشة الكبيرة ،
فمن أكثر الأشياء الممتعة
أن نرى المنتج النهائي
[موسيقى]